I've talked to you about this long long
long list of deplorable zin Donald
Trump's incoming cabinet it's a very
long list I can't rehash the entire
thing now but just to remind you of some
of the conspiratorial types that are
going to be part of Donald Trump's
cabinet we've got Deputy Secretary of
State John Bolton who went on Fox News
over the weekend and said that he thinks
that the entire Russian hacking of
democratic emails before the election
might have actually been a false flag
perpetrated by the Obama administration
he'll be Deputy Secretary of State I've
told you about Ben Carson who's the
neurosurgeon who will be running Housing
and Urban Development
he's also parroted conspiracies that for
example the Egyptian pyramids were built
by Joseph to store grain and that the
LGBT rights movement is just a communist
plot and then there's former General
Michael Flynn Trump's incoming national
security advisor who has repeated rumors
that Hillary Clinton might be involved
with occult practices and pedophilia all
of that pales in comparison to one of
Donald Trump's latest appointments what
I like to call a Fox News appointment
I'm talking about incoming deputy
national security adviser katie
mcfarland who last worked in government
during the reagan era in communications
the last ten years though she's been a
Fox personality and she reportedly got
this job because just walking around in
the hallways of Fox News she met Donald
Trump's two oldest sons Donald Trump jr.
and Eric Trump and I guess that
qualifies you now to work for the Trump
administration
here's her big theory back in 2006 katie
mcfarland ran for Hillary Clinton's
Senate seat and she claimed that Hillary
Clinton was so afraid of katie mcfarland
that she was using helicopters to spy on
katie to keep her under surveillance and
know everything that she was doing can
you imagine the deputy national security
adviser someone who publicly made up
that a member of the Senate was keeping
her under helicopter surveillance is
going to be the second-in-command to the
president when it comes to national
security by the way what can you even
really find out about people from a
helicopter it's sort of a weird way to
find dirt on
people other than like where they
physically are don't we need some kind
of psychological stability test for
people who will be serving in these
administrations Rachel I know that
people are often opposed to testing
anybody for anything because it's
discriminatory but if you're going to be
serving at this level don't we want to
know that you that you're at least
fundamentally stable psychologically
there should be some tests in place for
that but in terms of what she believes
her national security she's pretty much
a hardliner and it's definitely
streamlined with everyone else that
Trump is picking in terms of
surveillance of Muslim
oh yeah Asians with Iran and defense
spending so she fits in perfectly there
she just may not be mentally stable Yeah
right she has all of the normal views of
the Trump cabinet and in addition as a
bonus she thought Hillary Clinton was
using helicopters to spy on her we need
to get used to this guys I mean we've
got Republican control of Congress House
and Senate for the next four years in
addition to the White House if Trump
makes some Supreme Court picks which
he's expected to do we're looking at 30
to 40 years of influence over our
country with these type of nutty
selections and the really scary part and
this is why the fundraiser that were
doing at david pakman.com slash donate
is so important corporate media is
totally normalizing what's going on
almost every single one of Donald
Trump's elections are either total
lunatics and or fundamentally dangerous
to our country as people in positions of
power and corporate media has normalized
it they pretend Trump is like a normal
guy to be president they pretend that
these selections are even remotely in
the in the world of sanity we have to
fight the normalization of this Trump is
not a normal president this is not a
normal cabinet and for all the Trump is
to tell me Oh David you're just upset
that quote your candidate lost
tell me how these selections will make
America great again for you tell me
specifically for you based on your
socioeconomic status based on where in
the United States you live how will
these selections make America better for
you